y consultorios como estos están
repartidos por todo esa y siguen
funcionando incluso durante estos
tiempos de guerra aquí se da apoyo a
adictos enfermos de sida y a
trabajadoras de la calle que vienen
especialmente buscando asesoría en su
salud
y mejora software la situación no es
buena todo está peor no tenemos trabajo
los precios de los productos han subido
y mis nervios me están afectando
su mayor temor es morir que las maten
que las reste la policía su profesión es
arriesgada en sí misma incluso hay
chicas que trabajan teniendo vih
esta organización lleva años trabajando
con personas vulnerables especialmente
con mujeres víctimas de violencia sexual
y prostitutas pero dicen que ahora lo
que más les preocupa durante la guerra
son miles de mujeres con sus hijos
cruzando la frontera donde podrían ser
víctimas de tráfico de personas
hay un gran número de reclutadores de
proxenetas que ofrecen una variedad de
ofertas dudosas justo al otro lado de la
frontera y las mujeres que se encuentran
en un estado vulnerable pueden caer en
la trampa en el futuro tendremos una
gran cantidad de personas atrapadas por
la trata de personas y esto es realmente
aterrador creo que ahora no sabemos
mucho sobre eso pero el resultado lo
veremos después de algún tiempo
sólo tengo ansiedad tengo miedo de salir
de casa tengo miedo dejar a mi niña en
casa porque vivimos en el octavo piso
hoy perder a una hora de sus clases en
línea porque no puedo dejarla sola me
siento como una inválida una persona
enferma y una carga para todas las
fichas y eso viene y se ríe
las guerras siempre son duras para la
totalidad de la población de un país
pero esto es especialmente aún más
difícil para la población más vulnerable
esto es especialmente evidente en odessa
donde hay un gran número de prostitución
y adicción y por eso es tan importante
el trabajo que hacen organizaciones como
esta para proteger este sector de la
población